[Music]  Google I'm going to put my smart glasses  on for this final thought Google keeps  using those words diversity inclusion  and tolerance I do not think they mean  what Google thinks they mean the company  has sent a crystal clear message today  that they will not tolerate any hint of  the only diversity that matters  diversity of thought in the name of free  thought they suppress speech in the name  of diversity they exclude those with  diverse points of view in the name of  tolerance the high clerics of Google  will not tolerate era tix GK Chesterton  and orthodoxy identified Google's  illiberal central premise the thought  that stops thought there is a thought  that stops thought he wrote that is the  only thought that ought to be stopped  wise words  I'm Michael Knowles this is a Michael  Nolt show come back tomorrow and we'll  do it all again  [Music]  you  [Music]